here's the
question God accepted Abel's sacrifice
because it's from the flock whereas God
did not accept Cain's sacrifice because
it's from the
Harvest
now what you're asking me is does that
suggest that because Cain gave God from
the Harvest not an animal sacrifice
that's why it was
rejected so yeah kind of just like
symbolically speaking it was the work of
his hands and you know Jesus being the
lamb he covers Us and yeah they lamb so
yeah no not that because if you read the
law of Moses the Israelites were
required to give the first fruits of
their Harvest to God okay so it cannot
be that reason so when you hear people
saying well because Cain gave from the
Harvest not a sacrifice no actually no
okay because in the law of Moses
Israelites were required to give the
first fruits of their Harvest to God
that wasn't the
reason that wasn't the reason what did
your oh ask and he your priest talked
about it what was the reason God tells
you because Cain had an evil
heart sure here if you guys want to know
the answer it's in the Bible you don't
need to guess here Genesis
4 we're going to read three right here
to
10 here it goes
so that well yeah hold on yeah let me
start here let me start at one so let's
see why that's not the answer Genesis
let's start at one now that okay guys
pay attention here it is now
that now the man knew his wife Eve and
she conceived and gave birth to Cain and
she said I have gotten a man with the
help of Yahweh and again she gave birth
to his brother Abel Abel was a keeper of
flocks but Cain was a cultivator of the
ground now why would God expect Cain to
give an animal when he was a cultivator
of the ground you see the problem yeah
Cain is giving
from his line of work cultivating the
ground he's a tiller of the ground he's
a gardener Abel is giving from his line
of work he's a Shepherd he's a keeper of
flocks so why would God expect Cain to
give something other than from what he
does he tills the ground so give a
produce from the ground
when it's Abel who keeps flocks everyone
seeing it are you guys
listening so the answer is because Cain
did not give it from a pure heart his
heart was tainted because of jealousy
and anger how do I know well let's read
so it happened in the course of time
that Cain brought an offering to Yahweh
the fruit of the ground Abel on his part
also brought of the firstborn of his
flock and of their fat portions so do
you expect Abel to give produce from the
ground when he's a Shepherd what would
you expect able to give from what he
does right from the flock correct yeah
then why would we accept Cain to give an
animal sacrifice when he was a tiller of
the ground so if he's a tiller of the
ground what do we expect him to give
fruit from the ground yeah okay so then
what was the problem here's the problem
and Yahweh had regard for Abel and for
his offering but for Cain and for his
offering he had no regard so now the
reason so Cain became very Cain why are
you angry and why has your countenance
Fallen if you do well notice what he did
not say if you had given me an
animal right will you will not your
counts be lifted up no if you do
well and if you do not do well here's
the warning sin is lying at the door and
it desires for you but you must rule
over it then Cain spoke to Abel his
brother and it happened when they were
in the field that Cain rose up against
Abel his brother and killed him so God
saw his heart that's what 1st Samuel
16:7 says God does not see as man sees
he sees the heart and God saw that
Cain's heart was prone to evil and he's
warning him notice guys what God did not
say he didn't say if you had given me an
animal no if you do well
will not your face be lifted up and if
you do not do well I'm warning you
there's something wrong with your heart
with your attitude with your spirit and
I see through you I'm looking at your
heart and it's not right and therefore
sin this is a demon called sin is at the
door and it's going to control you if
you don't conquer it sadly Cain gave
into sin and became controlled by it to
the point now he lies to God then Yahweh
said to Cain where is Abel your brother
and he said I do not know am I My
Brother's Keeper he thought he could
murder Abel and get away with it and God
would not know and he said what have you
done the voice of your brother's blood
is crying out to me from the ground so
the simple answer is Cain's heart his
attitude his Spirit his disposition
wasn't right whereas Abel's was okay
that's why notice what Hebrews 11 says
Hebrews 11
right Hebrews 11 verse 4 watch here
Hebrews 11 verse4 by faith abble offered
to God a better sacrifice than Cain what
made it better his heart because he was
sincere before the Lord through which he
was approved as being righteous God
approving his gifts and through faith
though he is dead he still speaks that's
the
answer makes sense yeah see that's it's
beautiful you say the Bible in the wrong
head this is why I inquire this is why
I'm so inquisitive because I don't want
to speak wrongly of scripture or
anything like that see I read into it
too much and didn't take the text for
what it was so exactly appreciate the
clarity on that one um amen and so you
understand the point folks God doesn't
see only your Deeds he sees your heart
here let me show you okay let me show
you from scripture and he saw Cain's
heart was not right Cain's heart was not
right okay let me show you from
scripture and he's warning Kain check
your attitude your disposition your
heart 1st Samuel
16:7 but Yahweh said to Samuel do not
look at his appearance or at the height
of his stature because I've rejected him
for God sees not as man sees for man
looks at the outward appearance but yah
looks at the
heart right let me give you another
verse one second before I move
on right here you
go watch here Yahweh looks at your
motivations your inclinations your
disposition your inner person not just
your Deeds but Yahweh looks at the heart
and here Jeremiah 17:10 I Yahweh search
the heart see he's looking at your heart
he's looking at your thoughts he's
looking at your desires why are you you
doing what you're doing I test the
inmost being your inner person even to
give to each man according to his ways
according to the fruit of his deeds
that's the answer folks are you getting
it everyone listening now watch here
second Corinthians 510 for we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ so that each one may be
recompensed for his deeds in the body
according to what he has done whether
good or bad now when Christ will judge
us may have mercy on us May the blood of
Christ wash us is he just going to judge
you for your Deeds no watch here 1
Corinthians 4: 3 and 5 guys do not be
distracted learn your Bible 1
Corinthians 4: 3-5 Paul is telling the
Corinthians I could care less if people
judge me I could care less if people
condemn me I don't give a damn about
your opinion because you're not my judge
and I answer to the Lord so go ahead
condemn me what H are you that's what
he's saying here basically you don't
believe me here but to me it is a very
small thing that I be examined by you to
me I could give a damn if you're going
to examine me and question me or by any
human Court in fact I don't even examine
myself now let me explain what he means
here you guys got to learn
this he's saying I don't even trust my
own assessment of
my my faith and my Deeds I don't even
even go by my own assessment my self
analysis why because I can be deceived
watch
here watch
here for I am conscious of nothing
against myself yet I am not by this
acquitted did you understand what he
just said I don't even trust my own
opinion my self assist assessment
because I can be deceived even though
I'm not aware of
anything that I'm guilty of that doesn't
mean I'm acquitted you know why I can be
wrong I can be deceived I can be fooling
myself but who's going to examine me the
Lord but the one who examines me is the
Lord now look at the warning therefore
do not go on passing judgment for the
time but wait until the Lord comes who
will bring forth to light who both bring
to light the things hidden in darkness
and make manifest the motives of the
hearts
damn he looks at your heart he looks at
your motives he looks at why you did
what you did and then each one's praise
will come to him from God you understand
what Paul just said folks you understand
what Paul just said I don't even trust
my own self assessment I may be
deceiving myself thinking I'm not
blameworthy the Lord will then reveal
the motives of my heart he'll say Paul
you remember when you did
this here's why you did it so your
motives were not right before me so God
didn't look at Cain's offering he looked
at Cain's heart and his desires and sa
that Cain was not right before God he
had some problems
internally this is why David told
Solomon the following watch here see how
serious is serious it is if you want God
to then reward you strictly on what you
earn strict Merit all of us are going to
hell that's why it's Grace
look what David tells
Solomon watch here 1 Chronicles 29 28:9
as for you my my son Solomon know the
god of your father and serve him with a
whole heart and a delighted soul for
Yahweh searches all hearts and
understands every intent of the thoughts
if you seek him he'll be found but if
you forsake him he'll reject you forever
bye-bye once saved always saved see
that's
answer beautiful beautiful thank you so
much yeah that was very enlightening
because like I said I just I put my own
thought into that one and
then you just enlightened me so much so
I greatly appreciate of the holy spirit
all glory the spirit everything good may
he then purify us that we glorify Christ
and have mercy on me amen